this is Aaron guys it's the longest show
of all time
Aaron I said of lips on her she's on
Danny at all eggs
awesome she's my favorite that wasn't
gonna hot big brown get back in there
dude
yeah well no dude let's see that hair
like again is a real hair on there
scattered it in that was real could be
edit in it was that is that considered a
lot of hair let's go to the culture
corner we're here then my leg look I'm
asking dim Brendan nothing
definitely more hair than my leg - but
I'm witty girl you like dancing I don't
know I don't even it's just the fact
that she did it so [ __ ] huh you'd let
your girl girl here oh really yes she
doesn't but I mean she does it she's all
shaved up but if she did you see it this
kind of confidence wouldn't I be with it
mm-hmm Oh sexy I'm so high right now
yeah you're not here you at all just in
general right no Asians really don't
grow hair like that mm-hmm
but look I get where she's coming from
because it takes forever to shave your
legs so I don't blame her but I don't
like hairy legs personally but Bernie
you have to imagine you're making love
to a woman and you get to hold on to her
legs and they have hair on them you know
but also imagine it's real cold outside
okay no it's not that's such a hard note
for me yeah it's a no for me - I think
if you like you feel sick physically ill
let's see one more time make sure that
it's hair on there it's not a hairy
person you get a stomach look at her
armpit not judge her Brendon now I'll
say wait hold on play this again is that
her leg dude are we getting duped
oh dude you should be a detective yeah
girls with hairy legs no that's her like
no no no no hold up hold up
play it again feels on the Sun hold on
play it again
cuz she's not a hairy person look at her
other leg posit when you see both legs
pause go a little more did she go
anymore did we see any more of that
other leg man I don't think that's her
leg I think feels right cuz her other
leg doesn't even move looks like a man's
leg to me that might be a man dude this
is the dress blue or is the dress a
zebra you know what's that thing that
always happened yeah you right we put
this one out to see what people I have
to put this on social media can't say is
this her leg cuz there's a couple of
things going on here first of all she
seemed like a beautiful young lady and
everything like that super prom second
of all Shh she takes care of like her
teeth and everything so much you know
she looks like taking care of she have
phones I think some spray tan or a hand
tanner we rub tanner into your body yeah
we could her tummy yeah and then also
look at her okay and when her hand comes
in it looks like it has some of that
brown like tanner rub on it you know
that uh it's almost like that jerk
chicken stuff you put on but you put it
on your body you know the occasion
reasoning yeah
but women put it on him to look kind of
like brown at night or a brown during
the day and then they it gets all over
your sheets sometimes yeah chocolate
butter yeah chocolate body so I'm not
lying if this leg looks like a woman's
leg because it's not as tan as the rest
her buddy either
well her hands [ __ ] widen can you go
out is there is there any more to pull
down our scroll up or down on this video
itself is this we had that hairy leg
gate right now I'd like the fans maybe
maybe she could stand in another video
Oh a little stubble though is that
stubble though or is that actual
hair that no zoom in we probably can huh
God somebody can wear
oh no no no her armpits hairy I'm out
I'm out then you know how you get this
guy's about butt sex and come and [ __ ]
this makes me disgusting brain I don't
want to be part what'd he just say all
that day I was having a good day as well
yeah you weren't
now some girls have a condition like one
of Charles Manson's family members who
commit some of those murders how to
condition her legs were hairy [ __ ] yeah
who cares dude they murdered a bunch of
people saying she had hairy legs the
only other person I've known today that
doesn't mean that they should be a lot
of murder you're right dude when you're
right you're right I don't trust any
girl with hairy legs I mean I can
[ __ ] choke out the wood new white
camera guy or Louise with the fake name
over there yeah I'm not buying that with
that fake party look forward to it bring
on girls and beer yeah don't a party at
your house yeah don't [ __ ] me on girls
I just want to bait us there and then
[ __ ] scalp the white man I know
what's going on what's going on dude
with a [ __ ] arrow oh dude what does
she want relationship advice taken her
finger girls with hairy leg oh I'm out
didn't you say wow on a very special
King at her stinging all right now can't
handle it no very good girls like it
makes me sick I'm gonna go to hell
probably I've made a lot of poor choices
in my life already half there brother
I knew my legs don't
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]